à la résidence du centre de formation
professionnelle nunami biyour Savic la
chef lucinora prépare devant nous un
dessert cher à son peuple et qui fait le
bonheur de sa clientèle
on cuisine
des fruits frais mais de l'huile puis du
lait on peut utiliser de l'eau mais les
Inuits on préfère le des œufs de
poissons crus pour un dessert
on va apprendre ça puis on va les garder
pour faire les déserts
on va tout écraser puis après ça je vais
ajouter de l'huile
des œufs un quart gras avec le lait
avant il utilisait l'huile de Fuck puis
l'huile de béluga puis utilisez
[Musique]
les experts
aujourd'hui
on utilise
du lait oui quand c'est presque
[Rires]
tu vas voir le texter puis ça va être
vraiment sec comme la sauce hollandaise
ou la béchamel qui va prendre ok c'est
un dessert que ma grand-mère puis sa
mère puis la mère de mon grand-mère en
fait ça puis c'est
c'est important ici de transmettre le
savoir oui c'est vraiment important
parce que sinon on va tout oublier puis
nos enfants vont pas savoir c'est notre
identité
les recettes traditionnelles doivent
effectivement faire partie de la
transmission comme celle-ci le caribou
séchées
[Musique]
hypo ajoute un soupçon de sel avant de
laisser la viande séchée pendant 8 à 10
ans
[Musique]
à privilège
ça c'est la texture qu'on veut là
[Rires]
quand elles sont disponibles en été
début qui les bleuets ou la Camarine
noire sont utilisées pour ce dessert
[Musique]
vraiment Crimée je me dis c'est étrange
un goût de poisson avec des fruits mais
c'est vraiment subtil le goût de poisson
là et merci Lucie de nous avoir
accueilli chez vous bienvenue vous avez
cuisiné pour nous oui vous avez expliqué
comment vivait les vôtres vous avez
invité au bingo oui ça aussi qui a gagné
personne
[Rires]
comment on dit merci et les gamins chez
vous on dit la gourmet la Cormick c'est
suffisant pour tout ce que vous avez
donné et bienvenue ça veut dire
merci aux résidents qui nous ont permis
de s'immiscer dans leur quotidien